Bismillah. My name is Zabit. I'm a
post-graduate student of comparative
religion and I'm one of your biggest fan
Dr. Zakir. Welcome to Indonesia.
>> What was your name again? Once again,
>> Zabit.
>> I want to ask regarding to your lecture
universal brotherhood. Nowadays we find
many graduates of comparative religion
or we call it now as religious studies
who promoting toleration religious
harmony and interfaith dialogue yet in
which there is a heightened pluralism
agenda in it. What do you think about
this and how do we face it? Thank you.
If I understood the question correctly,
the brother is saying there are many
people who are doing studies of
compassionate religion and they're
having interfaith dialogue. Yes.
>> And trying to bring pluralism.
>> Correct.
>> Trying to believe that all religions are
same or equal.
>> Correct.
>> As far as interfaith dialogue is
concerned,
I'm not too much in favor of the
interfaith dialogue that normally people
have.
They have one Christian, one Hindu, one
Muslim coming and praising all
religions. So I tell them if the Hindu,
Christian or Muslim is coming together
on the platform and they're praising all
the religion, I'll ask the Christian,
will he become a Muslim?
>> He say no. Will the Hindu become a
Christian? And the answer is no. Will
the Muslim becomes a Hindu? And the
answer is no.
I believe in calling a spade a spade.
I rather talk about similarities rather
than saying
all religions are same. All religions
are not same. There are similarities. So
my formula is different. What I say? My
formula is simple. I say okay you
believe in one book to be the word of
God. They say yes. Christian they say
Bible is the word of God. The Hindus
they say that Veda is the word of God.
We Muslims we say Quran is the word of
God. So my formula is simple. Whether
you call interfere dialogue, whether you
call compare, I say let all of us agree
to follow what is common. What is
different we'll discuss tomorrow.
Let us agree to follow what is common
and not an object. Why should the
object? I'm you know in school we
learned about the ven diagram. If there
are three circles
the part which is overlapping all three
letters follow that.
So I in my compassion religion I try and
prove to them which I did today. Bible
says God is one.
The Hindu scriptures Veda says God is
one. Quran says God. Let us believe in
one God. Bible says God should not have
image. Vedas says God should not have
image. Quran says that. Why do we have
image of God at let us agree what is
common? What is different? We'll discuss
tomorrow. Right or wrong? There are so
many commonalities
in Jakarta on 18th of July.
after about 5 days from now I'm going to
give a talk on similarities between
Islam and Christianity
this is a master key come to common
terms as which is the most important
term in comparative religion Allah that
we worship but Allah so the most
important commonalities
Allah my son will be giving a talk on
20th of January concept of god image
religion the second most commonality I
gave talk 2 days ago in Manalang.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the various world religious scriptures
days ago on Thursday
most important one God number two
Mhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam if
you read the scriptures of all the major
world religions it talks about one god
to it talks about sallallahu alaihi
wasallam these are the main aspects then
you can talk about alcohol you can talk
about many things so this I believe in
interfaith nothing like your good my
good you scratch my back I scratch your
back
so Neither here, neither there. So if
you have interfaith dialogue have a
proper one like what the Quran says
no okay okay you are good I'm good both
are good but you are good I'm good both
are good if both are saying then you
should change correct
>> correct
>> I'm talking about similarities
so
we should keep Quran as our guide
>> in how to do dawa
many times when you go to these
universities
there may not be
Unfortunately, I have been to many
universities. We have which do PhD in
comparative religion. Okay. Muslim
university. I said brother how many
non-Muslim have you spoken to? He said
zero. You are doing comparative religion
for 4 years 5 years. You have not spoken
to any non-Muslim. What are you doing
for what?
Unless you want to become a non-Muslim.
What is the use? So something is
threatening, something is practicing it.
I am a practical man not a man.
>> Okay.
>> Practical. The practical dava is you
doing PhD in dawa and you haven't spoken
to a non-Muslim. What is the use of that
PhD?
It will not benefit you. It will not
benefit you in Jenna also. If you go to
Jenna, he will not take you to Jenna.
Sorry.
So we have to make Quran as our guide.
Follow the guidelines. And I've given
there's a uh there is a program there is
a course on Alhaya which I call as halal
Netflix let's become effective d
where I train how Muslims should use the
Quran and the other scriptures to
effectively convey the message of Islam.
Hope that answers the question.
>> Thank you.